。
同学们，我们说一下我们为什么选了蝴蝶效应这部片子啊，首先这部片子又是一部以小博大。你可以理解它对于新人编剧来说，这种故事是必须要学的，就像塑醉一样，因为人家以小博大，这就这种就是靠剧本突围的同学们。
我也可以带着大家去看，比如说超级商业大片是2012明明日之战啊，什么这种片子啊，也是大票房，也商业上非常成功。但是剧本上你说咱们学什么呢？对吧？他那种片子的剧本其实不要就主要就是别出错。
别出错就行了，对吧？那种大超级大鲨业片不依赖剧本的那种那种故事。呃，那种那种项目的话，你如果剧本写的过于创新，我跟你说，制片人还不要。
所以说它不是以剧本取胜的，它剧本就要70分，人家也不要多。我们举个极端点的例子吧。碟中谍或者007同学们，你们有没有看过有没有发现就是碟中谍和007这两个超级大IP它的剧本。
基本上就是70分的剧本。
他不会掉链子，但他也不会创新。像这种故事，你看啊它的剧本往往就是非常的刻板，非常的死板，对吧？那这种片子呢在咱们学习的时候，咱们就一般就不去学了，为啥嘞？因为这种项目他也不会找咱们去写，对吧？他别出错就行了，但是你看啊同样是谍战片，我告诉大家。
排第一的一定是007，排第二的一定是。
碟中谍这两个片子都不创新的，不创新。
谁创新啊？我告诉大家谁创新啊，马特达蒙。
谍影重重创新。
为什么你们知道为什么谍影重重创新？
因为他要突围啊，他如果也中规中矩，他能打得过007啊，是不是？但是他也想塑造超级谍战英雄的形象，他也想分一杯羹，所以你看啊作为小弟，他就要突围。他就他就搞剧本，他就拼命的搞剧本。
所以你看相反啊，谍影重重的剧本，咱凭良心说啊，谍影重重的剧本比007比谍成谍要好那么一丢丢，甚至说很不错。你你回你回忆一下是不是这么个道理，从评分上也能体现出来啊，因为咱们国家的那个评分平台那个评分系统。
基本上是按照故事结构和感染人程度，感染人的程度评分的。我跟你说，谍影重中的评分啊普遍来说要比碟中谍，或者是比那个比那个007要高那么一丢丢。007是最大的IP它评分最低。
理解理解这个逻辑吧，同学们同学们理解这个逻辑吧。这也是为什么啊，我我们说我们在学习剧本的时候啊，要选片子啊，所以后面我给大家选片子啊，你们有时候啊不能说哎呀这个片子我不喜欢看或者这个片子我们我给你们选什么片子啊，都是。
都是经过深思熟虑的，好吧，卷那部片子，一定有你必须要学到的东西，就像蝴蝶效应一样，一定有你必须要学的东西，颠覆你认知的东西。你如果不学你这辈子不会写的东西。首先啊来看一下这个蝴蝶效应，它的信息节拍。
它的这个奇特的信息节拍啊也不能说奇特啊，主要是确实是比较复杂啊比较复杂。我们说这个片子的信息节拍，或者是它的分分章节为什么复杂？同学们。
他有两大坨前十。
但是他这两大坨全史前十。
后来都是有用的，因为后面的循环都过去了，所以这两大坨前十是非常的有用的。你可以理解为是前十，你也可以理解是参对照组嘛，对吧？
虽然有20多分钟的两大坨前时，但是呢你可以理解它是个对照。
它是必不可少的，所以他又不算是个前十。这个这个属于这个片子的一个一个特点啊，我们来看一下，先看一下信息节拍，我们再去聊这些事情，好吧。
第一排一分钟用一个悬念开场，男主角呢很慌张的在躲藏啊，在躲藏。我们说。
悬念开场啊，不我们当然是信息不对称，不知道主角想干什么。但是塑造一个困境啊，他很害怕一个东西，他在躲藏，是可以加强这种可以加强这种期待感啊。同学们要学一下，就这种短暂的悬念开场，由于交代的信息不多。那么。
交代一个危险的境遇还是比较好好用的。好吧，交代他在躲藏某个躲藏什么东西，在躲避什么东西。
我们说第一拍第一分钟用一个小悬念啊开场。后来我们知道这个悬念就是最后就是后面某一场戏的前置。这个我在课上也讲过啊，所谓的倒叙不不是真正的倒叙，就是有一场戏的前置啊，这就是把一场小戏前置了。然后进个片头。所以说这一拍可有可无，你也可以认为。
就不是一拍也行啊。当然了，拉个期待是没毛病的。第一拍之后进了片头，然后来到第二拍，也就是第二分钟。
一个阳光明媚的社区，这时候我们男主角艾文啊还是个孩子。
然后呢，妈妈送他去上学，这里点了一下爸爸去不了家长会啊。然后呢，妈妈呢这个这个被老师留下来，因为老师说他儿子有点不正常。
画了一个谋杀的画啊，但是孩子呢却完全不记得这件事情啊。然后呢上来一个小悬念啊，上来就给了一个小悬念。
然后啊来到第三拍，第三拍，也就是说第5分钟妈妈呢带着我们这个男主艾文检查身体啊，这里呢。
暗示他的父亲也也是这样的，他是遗传他父亲的病啊，这里有几个重要的信息检查身体这一场。还有一个重要的信息呢，就是医生医生推荐他写日记来治病。
第四拍来到第6分钟啊，艾文啊并没有好转，这里有一场戏，就是艾文在家里突然拿起了刀。
啊，但是不记得了。
又不记得自己为什么要拿起刀，又一个小悬念啊，悬念堆满啊悬念堆满。
第五第五拍来到第7分钟，艾文被送去邻居家玩。
拍摄看起来。
并不太好的一个录像啊，这时候并不知道是色情录像，但是看起来不太好。然后艾文呢又失忆了啊又失忆了。
然后第六拍。
来到第8分钟。
又到医院去检查，结果还是一切正常啊，一一但是需要去见父亲，暗示父亲啊，病情很重，暗示父亲的病情很重。
第七拍第9分钟，精神病院去见探望父亲，但是父亲突然想要掐死他啊，然后父亲在这一拍里被打死了。
同学们记一下啊，7个斜拍的第一坨前十。
给了多少个悬念，大家自己去记一下。
来到第二陀前时第八个节拍，第11分钟。
明确写了6年后啊6年后，也就是第二个时间线了啊。少年团4个人啊，这说候少年组的。
刚才是幼儿组啊，现在是少年组，少年组的4个人，我们的艾文兰nytmy和凯y啊。
说一这个名字大家能区分吧？艾文是我们的男主啊，凯丽。
是我们的女主啊，安米是那个小胖子，汤米是女主的哥哥啊。
我们用男主女主、小胖哥哥来区分啊。
第八节拍第十1分钟，少年团4个人，男女主、小胖和哥哥找到了一个雷管，记住啊，四个人。
低一坨前十。
记得主要是悬念。第二坨前史主要给我记这4个人，当然悬念也继续给啊，悬念继续铺是四个人堆好了。
然后他们找到一个雷管，然后第九拍来到第12分钟啊，他们要去炸毁一个油箱啊，炸毁一个油箱，但是出事了。
出了什么事儿呢？又给悬念。因为。
我们的男主又失忆了啊，在这个失忆的之前给了一点小小的线索，我们这个小胖子呀倒下了啊。
然后呢，其他人好像都在撒谎，其他人都在撒谎，都说自己不知道这个事情，具体发生了什么事儿，我们男主又失忆了。
来到第十拍，也就是第15分钟。
写日记啊写日记。
然后呢，旧物箱里发现了爷爷的病例。
这里暗示爷爷也是疯子啊，跟他和他爸。
都是一样的情况。
第1一拍来到第16分钟去到去催眠治疗啊，催眠治疗医生想让他回忆起油箱当天发生的情况，就炸油箱当天发生的情况。然后艾文。
回忆失败啊，发病了醒过来非常的痛苦，还流鼻血。
根本回忆不起来。
现代医学救不了他啊。
第十二拍。
也就是第18分钟，我们这个少年团4人组去看电影啊，不是4人组，三人组啊。然后艾文呢，我们这个男主想知道那天的事情，然后这兄妹俩不告诉他啊，但是妹妹凯莉明显心里承受不了了。
暗示当天发生的事情很可怕啊，然后两个人接吻呢，被哥哥汤米发现了，哥哥汤米抱走啊，打他们。
然后被带走了。
第13个节拍22分钟，新闻报道新闻报道。
爆炸造成了恶性事件。然后我们男主的妈妈呢隐约觉得这件事情与儿子有关系，然后决定搬家远离是非之地啊。
然后第14个节拍，也就是第23分钟。
那个小胖子啊，来你出院了。
三个人出去散步。
他们发现汤米也就是哥哥在杀男主的狗。
然后男主呢想救狗的时候呢，再次晕倒啊，再次失忆black out是吧？再次失忆，然后又给了一个悬念。
来到啊第十五节拍，来到第26分钟。
男主艾文搬家离开和自己的这个女朋友，也就是这个凯y送别。
好，用了15个节拍来交代所谓的前十。当然你可以理解为前十，也可以理解为它是一个对照组，并不是一个前十。因为我们这个片子要不断的穿越平不断的穿越平行宇宙。所以说你可以理解它是就是个对照组，它也不完全是个前十。因为它花了27分钟。
同学们。
如果理解为前十的话，这个影片有27分钟的前十，而且分两个时间段，一个是幼幼年段，一个是少年段，是吧？好。
来到第1六盘，第27分钟，7年以后。
啊。
长大成人了啊，第三个时间线，成人组。
长大成人了。
我们这个男主长大了啊，在大学里面这个呃考试交卷，对吧？然后嘞展现他什么？展现他是个优秀的学生啊，春风得意，而且研究的方向是什么？研究人的记忆是吧？研究方向是研究人的记忆。
然后呢，第17拍第28分钟去酒吧啊，去酒吧庆祝庆祝啥玩意儿呢？庆祝7年没有晕倒过了，他不是经常晕倒，然后失去一段记忆吗？他庆祝自己7年没有经历过这个事情了，去酒吧去庆祝，这显然要找倒霉，一立flag就要找倒霉，是吧？
然后去酒吧，春风得意的她带了个妞儿回来是吧？带了个姑娘回来，然后在宿舍准备准备准备happy，然后嘞不小心翻出了日记是吧？翻出了自己小时候日记7年没动过了，然后他自己读了一段日记。
然后第1八拍第30，也就是来到第32分钟，他读日记读的是虐狗那一段啊，读的是。
读的是。
哥哥也就是那个汤米虐狗的那一段。
然后。
回想起来，当时被打晕晕倒这一小段啊，开始发现有点问题了。
是吧开始发现有点问题了。
因为他似乎感觉自己过去了一下，这里还不完全确定是在穿越啊。同学们，我们要回到我们当时第一次看这个电影的时候，这里可不是可不确定自己在穿越，对吧？
不确定啊，第1九拍也就是第34分钟啊，他去找那个小胖子拦你去确认一下这件事情。
结果发现莱尼精神出问题了。
一直就没有走出来过。
对吧他想要弄清楚当天的事情，发现这个小胖给的线索跟他。
穿越依次穿越的那一段台词是一致的。
然后第二0节拍第36分钟，他回来再次确认，我们说这叫。
再次这个拒绝召唤这个这个接受召唤，对吧？再次读日记。
又开了天眼是吧？又感觉又穿越过去了。
回到了雷管炸油箱的那一段。
他这次回到的是雷管炸油箱的那一段。
事情没有什么改变，雷管呢炸了一对母女，对吧？炸了一对母女，他看到了当年发生了什么事儿，是一个非常糟糕的一个回忆。
然后呢，他这次过去的时候呢，他当时叼的烟不小心掉到肚子上烫了个疤。
然后回来之后。
肚子上真的有了吧。当然我们看完全片知道这段是怎么回事，就是他他轻微的改变了历史，但是改变的不多，没有改变历史的大的走向，是吧？
但是当时就感觉到七跷了。
同时这场戏还有一个作用啊，就是解解答了当年的对照组的一个悬念啊，解答了一个悬念。
第21拍来到第38分钟，他继续调查这些事情，包括找他妈调查父亲的情况，对吧？感觉到父亲似乎也跟他有相同的问题，而且母亲的欲言又止也加深了他的怀疑。而且这里还有一场戏，母子两个人去算命。这个神婆呢也说了一些神神叨叨的话。
说他根本不属于这个世界，对吧？没有灵魂。
不属于这个世界，没有灵魂。
而且母亲呢也透露自己当年怀孕很艰辛，是吧？
呃，这个这个这个包括多次流产啊，欢迎很艰辛。
来到第22拍，第43分钟。
我们的主角继续去尝试读日记，试图唤醒更多的记忆啊，试图唤醒更多的记忆。
然后呢，这次他的调查呢去找到了凯丽啊，找到了凯丽。
两个人叙旧了，但是两个人已经是完全不同的世界了。
台历过得并不好，也就是说他当年小时候那个女朋友过得并不好，对吧？很落魄。
然后打听关于打打听凯利关于拍。
当年那个儿童片的事情。
我们说当年他们被那要求脱光了，一起拍拍拍视频。
他想知道怎么回事，当然我们能感受到一次是不好的视频，对不对？
凯丽并不愿意提起两个人不欢而散。
第23拍来到第49分钟。
接到了凯莉哥哥的电话，也就是汤米的电话。凯莉自杀了。
凯丽自杀了。
然后呢，他也去偷偷参加了凯丽的葬礼。
这是害的第一个人啊，凯丽自杀。第24拍来到第51分钟啊，觉得这一切都有问题。然后他又结合父亲的情况。
决定再次测试自己能否改变什么。
于是，他选择了回到拍儿童片的那一天。
怒斥了凯里的父亲，吓坏了对方，并警告对方要善待自己的女儿，并且管好自己变态的儿子。
这是他做的第一次改变命运线的举动。为什么要做这第一次改变呢？
是因为上一节拍。
凯莉死了，凯莉因为自己自杀了，这些关键点给我记住啊，记在脑子里。他这次他在这里做了第一次命尝试改变命运，是因为凯莉自杀了，他想要救凯莉。
他想要拯救凯莉。
第25个节拍来到第54分钟。
回到现在这个时间线，回到当前时间线，记忆重新填充大脑啊，再次流鼻血。
再次流鼻血。
发现啊确实改变了是改变了命运线了啊，改变命运线了。
凯莉现在和自己是恋人。
自己也确认了自己能够改变历史。
自己是一个受人欢迎的校园明星，对吧？
很多事情都改变了。
凯丽确实被拯救了，而且跟自己是恋人，两个人很甜蜜，而且两个人在学校都非常受欢迎，是风云人物，对吧？
然后第26拍也就是第60分钟。
享受这个快乐的生活。我们说在这里第一次改变，怎么也得享受一段红利，对吧？在学校里还挺屌的。
对吧生活很快乐，而且自己好像是还是个小恶霸，可以欺负别人是吧？
跟沈腾第一次穿越一样是吧？就很开心，可以可以享受红利。
但这个红利很短暂，来到第27拍。
第64分钟。
和凯丽约会的时候呢，被哥哥汤米给破坏了。
汤米刚刚释放。
成为了最大的威胁。
对吧？
艾文意识到意识到一个什么问题啊。
就自己虽然救了凯莉。
但是。
去。
太了。
汤米。
汤米现在成为了一个极端暴力、极端变态的人物。然后汤米甚至要殴打艾文，要杀了艾文，结果艾文在反击的时候错手杀死了对方，我们的男主角错手杀死了汤米。
然后来到第28分钟啊，第28拍也就是第70分钟。在监狱里，艾文被收监啊，我们同学们要理解啊，这个这个这个这种重重罪没判之前要被收监的啊，这个还是很合理的，然后被收监被霸凌。
在监狱里被霸凌，明白吗？
然后来到第29拍第72分钟，当然了，霸凌会写各种戏啊，同学们自行去看没看的，自行脑补，肯定是就被各种骚扰呗。
第29拍来到第72分钟啊。
律师短期内来不了啊，律师短期内来不了，然后他要求妈妈给他送日记来。这个同学们也觉得是符合逻辑的啊，因为他要穿越。
因为他要重新改变历史。
然后呢。
就给他，但是只有两本，只送来两本啊。
第3十拍。
第74分钟再次被欺负啊，日记也被抢。
被打日记被抢，然后仅存的几个日记片段呢。
不是没有重要节点，改变不了重要节点是吧？不适合穿越。
来第31盘。
第76分钟啊第76分钟。
嗯，虽然没有重要节点，但是可以回到当年画画的课堂，对吧？所以他回到当年的画画的课堂，画下了很可怕的画，给自己制造了一个疤痕啊，给自己制造了一个疤痕，然后让狱友相信自己是耶稣啊，自己是耶稣，利用这个计划夺回日记。
顺利穿越而去，对吧？虽然没有虽然没有关键节点，但是他用一个平常的节点也制造出一个。
东西，然后利用这个狱友的配合啊，夺回了他的重要日记，然后穿越而去。
同友们可以理解啊，这个是一个这个耶稣的隐喻啊，耶稣的隐喻。
32节拍来到第80分钟，他回到了哪个关键节点呢？又回到了烧狗那一天，他带着兰妮去拯救自己的狗，也就是带着小胖子去拯救自己的狗，一切又重演。他这次说服汤米，因为是汤米在第一次在第在第一层平行宇宙里啊，汤米没能拯救这个狗，所以很自责。
变得变得那个有点那个精神不正常。他在这个版本里面呢。
给了这个兰妮一个利器是吧？让利让兰你这次能够顺利把狗解救出来。
但是在这次呢莱尼由于对汤米有记恨啊，结果。
来，你把汤my给宰了。
搞出事情了。
来。
第33排第第82分钟，再次回到当前的这个时空，再次回到当前的这个时空，记忆再一次重新点填充。而且这一次呢暗示一次比一次更痛苦，对吧？昏迷，然后去检查身体呢也验印证了为什么一次比一次更痛苦，因为他大脑中塞入了太多的记忆。
要爆炸掉了，对吧？
然后第34拍来到第84分钟。
我们的这个。
主角啊潜入医院寻找莱妮，发现莱尼已经被当成了精神病，因为他杀人嘛，对吧？
被锁住，完全被剥夺了自由。然后安妮而且直直白的谴责艾文剥夺了自己的人生啊。
然后第35拍，第86分钟。
他决定再次冒险穿越啊。
这次穿越呢，他去找他父亲来到跟他父亲见面那那个时间段，他想去咨询他父亲咋解决这个问题。果然啊他父亲啥都知道，他父亲也知道你穿越过来了，俩人都一一个一个情况。
然后呢。
这也也解答了他父亲为什么要掐死他，对吧？又解答了一个悬念。
然后第36拍，第87分钟。
他去找凯莉，发现这个版本里，凯莉已经沦为了一个吸毒的妓女。
他试图说出对说服对方，但是呢并不被信任啊并不被信任。
第37拍第94分钟，他决定重新改变历史进程啊，重新改变历史进程。回到油箱爆炸啊，油箱炸弹的那天啊，重新改变历史。因为这个版本里面他要救谁啊？我们再来回忆一下第一个版本救谁啊？
第一个版本救凯莉对吧？第二个版本虽然是害了t米，但他不是为了救tmy，是因为他自己他妈进监狱了，对吧？但是出来之后呢，结果发现又害了兰尼，那他穿越是为了救兰尼吗？也并不全是兰尼虽然也被害了，但主要还是救凯莉，是吧？
这小子挺自私的对吧？所以第三次决定再一次去改变历史进程。
当然了，你也可以理解，就来你，对吧？来你也确实被他害了。
然后呢，这一拍呢又回到油箱炸弹那个现场，他决定自己去把炸弹去去去去销毁啊，拯救那对母子，结果呢自己被炸伤了。
他自己被炸伤了。回到现实之后呢，回到现实之后呢，发现兰尼是自己的室友啊，回到自己呃发现兰你是自己的室友，但是自己已经没有双手了，是吧？再次重新填充记忆，兰尼和凯莉过着幸福的生活是吧？汤米也很正能量。
就这个版本呐。
汤米也很正能量，来你和凯莉也过着幸福的生活，就是自己没有手。然后来到第338拍，也就是第98分钟，他和凯丽单独交谈啊，就发现哎操这个结局好像大家都挺好的，是吧？大家也都对自己很很照顾，很爱自己，所以他有点不忍心再去改变了，他很纠结。
那吧他很纠结。
发现这个版本除了自己残废了，其他都挺好。然后呢第39拍。
也就是来到第101分钟，那结局很显然，对吧？我自己死了算了，他决定自杀，决定自杀。这时候呢没死成汤米来把他救了，老好人，汤米来把他救了，是吧？女主的哥哥来把他救了，是吧？汤米确实现在就是个纯粹的好人呀，是吧？
然后呢，但是这个版本里面呢。
呃，救了他之后，他发现他妈。
他妈。
得了。
最矮。
是吧他发现在这个版本里并不是所有人都很好，妈妈又被害了啊，妈妈又被害了。于是他决定再冒险一次啊，他决定再冒险一次，再去整一下子。
然后妈妈这时候再次强调，你跟你爹一模一样，别折腾了，你们也不知道在折腾什么，你们这些神经病，对吧？因为确实只生活在一个时空的人。
是听不懂他们在说什么的，他们相当于是一个四维的动物，对吧？其他人都是三维的，而它是四维的，它能看到其他平行宇宙。
来来到第40趴，也就是104分钟。
他再次去寻找日记啊，寻找日记，发现一个什么情况呢？就是他后来手被炸了，他只有手被炸掉之前的日记了，是吧？回到那个小时候翻出一把刀那天啊，翻出一把刀，他其实是回到了拍录像的那天。
他翻出了一把刀，想要去办点大事，结果被母亲打断了，结果又回来了，解答了他那天为什么拿过了一把刀啊。
然后呢再次过去再过去呢又回到那天，然后呢找到雷管想要阻止呃想要威胁的那个那个那个凯莉的父亲，别拍这些那个儿童色情片，结果不小心把凯莉又给炸死了，是吧？在这个版本里面，他不小心把凯丽给炸死了。
然后被凯丽把凯丽炸死之后呢，再次经历全部的痛苦记忆，醒来之后就直接在医院里了。
醒来之后就直接在医院里了是吧？然后呢，他就不断的向医生去要日记。但是在这个版本里，由于他很小的时候，就把凯莉给炸死了。所以他一直处于精神病的状态。在这个时间，在这次的历史进程当中，。
他一直就处于精神病的状态，因为他用雷管把自己的好，他作为一个小孩，用雷管把自己好朋友炸死了，对吧？所以他在这个版本里面的成长就一直不好。
然后呢已经病入膏肓啊，正是这个版本都没有日记了，他也没办法去找到新的解决方案了。第41拍第10第109分钟，他又得到了一个新的线索。其实不光日记可以穿越，可以改变这个进程，一切能够勾起回忆的东西都可以。
图片图像也行。所以呢他这一次利用家庭录像，想利用家庭录像再一次改变历史。也这然后就呼应了开头那场戏啊，潜入办公室，然后留下绝命信是吧？然后呢呼应了第一场。然后他这次呢观看的是自己出生的时候的录像。
也就是妈妈生自己的时候，因为在西方啊，有些人家里生产会拍这种家庭录像。
然后呢，回到了母亲的胎中，用脐带。
把自己给勒死了。
从源头解决了问题。
因为他自己认为自己本来就不应该存在。
然后给了一个相对开心的一个，就是他勒死自己之后，来到第42拍，也就是第112分钟，如他所愿啊如他所愿。
每个人都健康的成长，幸福的生活，只有自己从来没有存在过啊。42拍。我们先说一下啊，有些同学看的是另外一个版本。
区别不是很大啊，只是时间和结局有所不同。我待会再讲一下另外一个版本。
现在讲的这个是导演剪辑版啊，导演剪辑版我们再来说一下。
另外一个版本。
另外一个版本最大的区别是什么呢？另外一个版本是院线版，院线版的结尾没有这么黑暗，并不是说回到胎胎中勒死自己。它回到了什么地方呢？
他回到了。
小时候的家庭录像，小时候有一次过生日，一次崭新的家庭录像。然后呢，他跟凯里是很小的小朋友的时候。
他把。
凯利给吓走了。
他选择不和凯里成为朋友，然后把凯里给撵走了。
然后凯莉呢在父母离婚之后，跟着妈妈去生活了，这四个命运纠缠的四人组没有在一块儿长大。
以各自成长，反而各自生活的比较健康。
这就是另外一个结局。
这个片子有两个结局啊两个结局。
所谓什么四个结局，你们不要去信啊，那些四个结局只是微小的区别，回头没回头那种啊。
两个结局。
就是这两个结局。第一个结局呢。
就是他勒死了自己，让自牺牲了自己，成全了所有人。
第二个结局呢相对比较柔和，并没有牺牲自己了，就是去穿越到当年。然后跟凯里说，我恨你，你快滚，然后两个人就没有成为朋友，然后那个人就跟他哥哥去跟妈妈搬走了，跟妈妈生活去了。然后所有人各自不打扰啊，各自不打扰。
懂吗？就这两个结局。
一般来说，大家都比较倾向于用勒死自己这个结局。
同学们。
一般来说，我们都比较倾向于哎，勒死自己是第一个结。假设勒死结局是一。
然后呢，两个人再无瓜葛是2同学们，你们选什么？我我先说一下我的观点，我也选一。
为什么啊？有几个原因？第一个原因就是勒死自己，让自己从来没有存在过，以便不要去打扰这个世界。这个片子这样搞逼格更高啊，逼格更高，这是第一个原因。我们坦率讲啊，确实逼格更高。
这是第一个原因。
第二个原因是吧，第二个原因。
所谓的这个。
哪个版本更更让人松一口气，安放情绪，我觉得也是死了更安放情绪。因为我们的主角太遭罪了，他其实太遭罪了，对吧？太遭罪了，没有必要再折腾他了，让他死了得了，我觉得死了反而是happy ending典，对吧？这是第二个原因。我觉得他从即便是从happy ending定的角度。
我都选一第三个原因，婴儿在胎中自杀，把自己勒死，这是很创新的一个画面呀。同学们啊，这是很创新的一个画面？我们说电影它最终毕竟要用画面来呈现这种画面是什么样的脑洞才能想起来啊？
好不容易想出来这么一个画面，那必须得拍呀，这有什么好扯淡的呢？必须得拍呀，这这这这是第三个原因。第四个原因，我们抛开一切，就说哎逻辑。
我们抛开一切，就说逻辑。
同学我们都知道啊，所有的穿越片都有悖论。穿越本身就是个悖论。同学们穿越本身就是个悖论，它不可能完全圆的起来。
穿越本身就是一个悖论，不可能圆的起来。所以每一个穿越类型的片子都在不断用各种方式去给自己圆逻辑，当然不可能圆起来，但是都在给自己圆。
这个片子呢它用的是平行宇宙来源。
但是它里面有一个重要的基础，就是你人生的关键节点才能改变你。
它里面有一个比较重要的一个理论根基，就是就那几个关键节点是能产生重大改变的。
否则的话，他也不用去专门去找那几个关键节点了，否则的话也早就解决问题了。他随便看任何一天的日记，然后穿过去，然后找到那个凯里说，我要跟你分手不就都解决了吗？
对不对？从逻辑上啊，首先我们要承认所有的穿越片逻辑不可能完美，不可能绝无可能。
所有的穿越片逻辑不可能完美啊，绝无可。
但是作者必须去想办法啊想办法。
去圆。
在这个电影里面，它用的是关键节点平行宇宙论。也就是说在某些节点是可以分叉出平行宇宙的，但是有些节点不可以。
因为如果按照最后这个解决方案，就是跟凯利分手就可以，每个时间段都可以跟凯丽分手。
对不对？
你在幼儿的时候跟凯里分手，你们俩人还啥都没谈呢。
实际上啊。
也就是说。
他这个片子后面为什么一直选那几个关键节点？实际他想说平行宇宙啊，他想说平行宇宙，他是用平行宇宙来解决穿越悖论的。我们说平行宇宙是出现在穿越以后的啊。
平行宇宙咋出现的？实际上就是穿越解决不了，有些人发明了一个词。
明白吧？
平行宇宙就是穿越题材，拍到最后，大家吵来吵去，有些人灵机一动说，嗯，其实是穿平行宇宙。
明白吗？所以说啊我比较倾向于第一个结局，同时也给大家讲了一下啊，同学们去在写穿越题材的时候啊。
不用太追求逻辑，差不多就行了。
我跟你们说，你们也逻辑不了。
本身就有悖论的。
如果穿越真的存在，我们现在就应该知道人类的结局，他们会过来告诉我们的，对不对？
我们来看一下这个片子下面一个知识点啊，我们来一起研究一下下面一个知识点。关于这个片子的超强前十。
超常前十。
我刚才说了，你可以理解为是前十，也可以理解他是对照组。
同学们，你们愿意把它理解为前十，还是理解为对照组呢？首先我们要明确一点啊。
在那一坨东西结束，那两坨东西结束之前，故事是没有进入启程转合的。
这一点首先我们要明确把。
在那27分的东27分钟的东西结束以前，故事并没有进入启程转合。这一点我们先达成这个共识。
因为我们的主角还没有开始行动，懂吗？
我们的主角还没有撬动蝴蝶效应，还没有开始改变历史进程，甚至都没有动这个心思。
所以说那27分钟的东西它显然是一个前十，或者我们可以理解它就是个对照族。
我们需必须要他。
那我们就来解决一个问题，这么一大坨东西没有动机，咋整？
这么一大坨东西没有动机，咋整？同学们27分钟的东西没有近戏，主角没有动机怎么办？观众不爱看怎么办？
或者观众气剧怎么办？
你们有没有想过这个问题，你们有没有这这么说吧，你们有没有人弃剧第一次看确实有是吧？
我告诉你，他肯定当然他存在这个问题，他怎么解决的啊？同学们他怎么解决的啊？
第一个你们答案已经说了。
就是用悬念。
给了挺多悬念去引起你的期待。
这是第一个方法。但是我们说这个方法不一定都灵的，为什么？第一，你时间太长了，接近30分钟啊，27分钟啊。第二，你光给一堆悬念，一点答案都不给有点掉我们胃口掉的过于多了呀。
我们说这是第一个方法，确实是用悬念掉了一下。
第二个方法，他用什么把尺度？
拍色经。
小孩拿刀要杀人。
雷管放在油箱里炸死一个婴儿，烧死一只狗，用的是大尺度。
同学们，这部片子在美国差点都没过筛。
他原剧本写的尺度可大了。
在美国都过不了山啊，同学们。
用大尺度再往下看一看，还能有啥？说用了这两种方法啊，用了这两种方法。
我们要知道，我们心里要明白啊我们要明白，来熬过前27分钟，故事进入启程转合就很过瘾了。为什么呢？首先非常前面有那么大的铺垫，进入启程转合之后，你跟对照组的悬念都能呼应上，何其过瘾。
对不对？同学们啊，这部电影一旦熬过前27分钟，后面真正进入启程转合。我们说进入启程转合，他拯救了几次啊？
第一次拯救凯丽。
对吧第二次。
所谓的拯救tom米，但其实是因为他被他失手把tmy杀了嘛，其实也是拯救自己啊。你可以那我们就我们就先按照人给他分啊，第一次拯救凯丽，第二次拯救t米，第三次拯救兰尼，对吧？第三次兰ny成为杀人犯之后，他又拯救兰ny，然后第四次拯救母亲。
救了4次。当然了，你可以理解啊，全都是来寻找完美生活。当然了，他穿越不止4次啊，穿越了七八次了，对吧？但是一旦熬过前27分钟，后面进入启程转合，全是爽点，不断的解答之前的悬疑，不断的对照组发生变化。
你眼睁睁的看着这个人，刚才是一个穷凶极恶的人，现在变成一个温文尔雅的人，眼看着刚才他是大学校花，现在是一个街头妓女，对吧？后面的爽点就很足了，后面的启程转合也比较明确了，对吧？那进到启程转合之后呢，那显然就是先发现这个问题，对吧？
看到自己可以救人，可以修正历史，发现这个问题之后，决定怎么去修正历史。为什么决定的？因为凯里自杀了，对吧？凯里自杀凯里自杀了，他决定修复历史。
然后修复历史修复历史开始是尝到了一些甜头了，也确实救了凯里。但是他后来发现这个胜利是假的，因为会害了别人。
明白吗？
然后再次去寻找解决方案，但是已经不行了，已经开始越走越远，事情越来越失控。然后最后的解决方案是杀了自己。
他组织故事的线索是按照人物组织的，对不对？挨个救呗。
来，我们来看一下这故事什么类型。
我之前讲过，穿越都是如愿以偿，在这里是否成立？我们来说一下如愿以偿这种故事类型有。
穿越这种情况是一是我们人啊一个愿望和期许啊，然后呢我们。
实现了这个愿望之后呢，开始是能享受到红利的。
然后后来呢又被这个。
愿望给伤害了。
又受到了他的诅咒。那最后我们的解决方案是什么呢？
解决方案是一切不要去动它，我不要这个。
如愿以偿是最好。
珍惜眼前人嘛，维持原状嘛。我们说如果我们细说这些元素的话。
确实都有确实都有。
也就是说。
他发现可以。
穿越可以改变命运，然后他尝试去改变命运，吃到了红利。我们说吃到了一点点红利啊，吃到了一丢丢在哪里呢？
享受红利在第60分钟一点点啊，还不光那个报得美美人归还成为了。
还成为了这个这个这叫什么学校的一个小霸王是吧？但是我们说这个红利呀一共多少时间啊？
10分钟。
吃红利吃的。
有点短哪，那我们先把故事类型放下，我们来说一下故事。
故事的主角。
显然是艾文是个男主。
我们来问。
故事的主角他想干什么？改变命运。对他想寻找完美，对吧？寻找完美的生活。
如果我们定性为主角寻找完美的解决方案。
这么一个故事线的话，那么用金羊毛去理解。
似乎更好。
因为不断的穿越，只是他的一个手段，并不是他的愿望。因为他根本不想穿越。
我们说如愿以偿里面有一个很重要的原则，就是这件事情是个好事儿，降临到你头上了。所以大家回忆一下夏洛特烦恼教大家怎么写，前半段吃红利，后半段被诅咒结局。
维持现状。
是最好的答案。
那从这个角度来说，这个电影可真的就不是一个典型的如愿以偿。
因为他一直在遭受诅咒。
这个穿越这件事情对他来说从来就不是个红利。
一直就是要他命啊。
只有短短的10分钟的红利，而且还发现是个假红利，对吧？很快就发现是个假红利。
所以你可以理解这个人在寻找一个完美的解决方案。
利用平行宇宙或者利用穿越这个手段。
在寻找解决方案。也就是说，在这个片子里面，穿越只是它的一个工具。
他想寻找完美人生。
从这个角度啊。
从大结构上来说，更符合金样的。
你从题材角度，我们说他当然是穿越。
但是从大结构的角度，它更像金羊毛。
我还是那句话啊，分类没有那么重要，因为上帝造物的时候也没有给他分类，对吧？分类只是一种学习方法，但是我们如果要探讨分类，如果要给这个类型的片子探讨分类，那你要知道他不是个典型的如愿以偿。如果按照夏洛特烦恼，我教你们的。
写如愿以偿的方法，那这个片子就没法写了。
同学们，如果我们没有看过这个电影。
我们真的按照如愿以偿去写这个电影应该怎么写？
我们肯定不会像人家这么创新，我们会按照教科书去写。
我们现在发现，我们只要看日记就可以穿越，我们不断的穿越回之前的人生某个关键节点，不断的给自己制造福利，不断的给自己加buff，不断的让自己更牛逼。
直到故事终点的时候，我们大脑才开始爆。
我们的脑子开始爆了，我们的亲友离开我们了，失控了，死人了。
然后我们才开始再开始挽救。
所以说这个片子它创新，它让人眼前一亮，是因为他没有按照。
如愿以偿去洗。
金羊毛写的。
按照我现在我的男主。
我要寻找一种完美的人生解决方案，去拯救挨个拯救我身边所有的人。我再回到我刚才给大家提示的。
他的线索实际上是挨个拯救的啊。
凯历。
第一个啊，女朋友，第二个tommy女朋友的哥哥，第三个来你是吧？
然后第四个，他妈。
再讲一个知识点，刚才这个知识点自己记住啊，自己去掌握，再讲下一个催化剂主角催化剂主角啊，这种电影显然要写催化剂主角，而且是催化剂主角的极限拉扯，是大催化。
不断的扮演救世主。
我们说过去为什么会有催化剂主角？
来，同学们，我们说在古典教材里面，为什么有一种主角会叫催化剂主角？
其实催化剂主角原本不叫催化剂主角，叫什么？
叫催化剂英雄，在古典故事里面是有这种催化剂英雄的。
实际就是就是。
西方文化的救世主是谁呀？
耶稣是吧，你们看他这个样子，你们你们你们告诉我大讲这个片子他想表达什么？
你们看看他这个他最后这个半相。
还不够明显啊，他这个片子不断的暗示啊，他就是想讲。
神救众生啊神能救众生这么一个故事。
你们刚才不是说还想看。
那个 triangle嘛是吧？
同怖游轮也是一个。
圣经的故事啊，也是一个圣奇的故事，这也是神救众生的一个故事。好吧，那在这个故事的主题里面啊，他选选寻找完美的解决方案。那最后的结局就是没有完美的人生啊。这个故事的主题就是同这个故事想讲给我们的道理，或者想传给传达给我们的价值观传达我们给我们的主题。我曾经给大家讲过啊。
主题这个东西啊主题它是个范围，这个这个故事的主题显然是关于人生完美人生，对吧？什么是完美的人生，什么是完美的生活？
这个故事的主题显然是这样的。
主题它是个topic。
他是个话题，那他的结论是什么呢？
结论就是没有没有完美的人生，没有人能。
没有人能扮演上帝，懂吗？
这就是这个故事，他想表达的东西。所以说同学们在这个故事里，我们学会几样东西。第一，如愿以偿穿越这种东西啊，它未必一定写成如愿以偿。它可以写成金羊毛，他把如愿以偿当成了一个纯诅咒，而不是红利。我们说如愿以偿啊，那种故事类型。我们说它一半是红利，一半是诅咒。
在这个里面，它纯纯的全是诅咒，纯纯的全是诅咒。所以像这种片子比较阴暗。为什么红利那段他不给我们玩啊？
全是诅咒。
如果我们写一个电影，我们是追求平衡的。
我们会让它一半红的一半诅咒，因为平衡的电影大家看着最舒服最爽。这种电影显然看了不爽呀，你显得你看了不舒服呀。这种电影你看了不舒服的，因为它能量不平衡。
他没有让你爽一半，然后再痛苦一半，他全让你痛苦。
全让探索。
懂吧？这是我们学到的啊，就人家电影他这么写，他肯定是冒险的。
肯定是有风险的。
但是非常规套路，有时候确实也能杀出血露。所以你可以理解为它是个金刚猫。然后它的超长的潜史，我们说那是个对照组，也确实很冒险。我们怎么去解决，对吧？也有方案。第三，所谓平行宇宙，所谓穿越没有合理的逻辑，不可能完美。
对吧第四，催化剂主角其实就是英就是英雄啊，就是催化剂英雄。这个挨个拯救救众人救是人。
对吧然后最后就是关于这种这种故事的主题，你可以理解它还是一个西方的文化，西方的审美讲耶稣。
所以西方人看这个片子啊，比我们更容易共情，对吧？讲耶稣嘛。
好吧，这就是这个片子。为什么啊？我给大家选这个片子，现在大家理解了，因为它太不典型了啊，但是它又太值得我们学习了。前面怎么铺悬念，后面怎么挨个兑现，在这么小的操作空间里面，它的爽感是怎么来的？然后如何用这么一个。
晦色的治愈的故事去讲一个大大的主题，讲一个耶稣诞生的一个主题。行，那咱们今天就这样了，好不好？
。